At least you're out in the world.
You must meet a lot of girls.
[MatPat] Barry, is that why you left the Beehive?
To meet lady bees?
Because I hate to break it to you, but... you already have.
Hey, those are pollen jocks!
Wow!
Hey Jocks.
What do you think buzzy boy
Are you Bee enough?
I'm not talking about those ones right there
I'm talking about THOSE ones. worker bees that go out and gather pollen what you know as the pollen jocks
Yeah, they're all female [dun dun dun]
A L L  F E M A L E
*donkey noise*
QUE THE MUSIC
Hello Internet welcome to film theory!
the show that's about to give BuzzFeed a run for its money, duh *pun intended*
Hey it all makes sense to me now after staring at this stupid
Movie for WAY too long something just clicked as I'm writing this script you notice
Everyone's hair cut in this movie the women all have beehive hairstyles obBEEous joke is obBEEous
But the guys they'll have buzz cuts buzz cuts and here you'll think that my jokes are bad
This is a REAL movie that ran in REAL movie theaters
Ladies and gentlemen this
Ｐｒｅｍｉｕｍ Ｃｏｎｔｅｎｔ
I'm sure by now. You're all familiar with the memes coming out of the B movie
But in case you've never actually stopped TO WATCH the movie, or you did watch it
But need a refresher because the plot wasn't exactly the most memorable thing about it well (yeah thats exacty what i was gonna say)
Then here's what you need to know Barry B.
Benson is a honeybee who travels outside of the hive falls in love with a human woman named
V A N E S S A
[Saxy Voice] "You Coming?" (NOT YOUTUBE FREINDLY)
[No]
And eventually uncovers a shocking conspiracy the bees are being enslaved by humans to produce, honey
[Vanessa] it's just Honey, Barry
[that retarded bee] Just- What? Bees don't know about this
This is stealing a lot of stealing [MatPat]so Barry decides to sue the entire
Honey industry and WINS. as you can imagine this has some unintended
Consequences. Now that humans are no longer eating honey, the pollen jocks that harvest nectar for the hive
No longer have to work and that causes the world's plants to start wilting so it's up to Barry [And V A N E S S A]
To find the last remaining flowers in America and pollinate plant life on earth before it's too late
Oh, and a buncha of bees team up to save a commercial jetliner from crashing
Oh, yeah, there's also that moment where[V A N E S S A] dies in a gruesome parasailing accident [Spoiler Alert
:
[Gruesome Crash]
RIP.
SO MANY things are wrong about this film. The fact that bees and humans can apparently
Talk to each other yet Barry's the first bee ever to try striking up a conversation
with anyone [ya like jazz?]  just the fact that Barry has a
romantic rival and that romantic rival is a human but besides that the fact that Ken his romantic rival has a bee allergy that the
movie just treats like a joke even though Bee allergies [Anaphylaxis] are very real and very serious medical problems
I mean seriously you think that people are spending hundreds of dollars on
EpiPens just for the LOLS? And yet ken is the one who's treated like the villain because he doesn't want to be in a room
with the bee who could potentially kill him and all of this wrapped in a movie about a love affair between an
insect and a human NAY Jerry
Seinfeld and a human perhaps worst of all is the message of the film that bees are a VITAL part of the ecosystem
And without them plant life as we know it would be wiped out because this simply isn't true in fact
It's the complete opposite from us
[V A N E S S A] And the environment as a whole would be better off if Barry B Benson, and his brash buddies would just buzz off. Permanently.
Yeah, I know. We're all trained to love bees at this point, but get ready because today. I'm gonna prove
how everyone especially the 🅱🅴🅴 movie has been lying to us.
Now what got me started on this episode was something I said a few weeks ago in the Tide Pod episode
Honeybee populations are on the rise for like the first time ever and I shared that as a positive news story
But after I finished that episode it got me researching we hear all the time that honeybee
Populations are on the decline and that this is a terrible thing for the ecosystem
But is it really? I was honestly surprised by what I found first honey bees aren't actually native to North America
They're an invasive species that was first introduced back in
1622 when European settlers brought 'em over the Native Americans even called them ''the white man's fly''. let's be clear, they weren't brought over for
Their ability to pollinate plants, but rather for their honey honeybees we see in the U.S. Like Barry B. Benson all just started as
''Agricultural animals'' like cows probably more accurately, like chickens. Chickens are used to produce eggs, bees are used to produce honey.
It actually took another 200 years before honeybees were brought over to California during the gold rush in
1853 and of course, in all of that time it's not like the North American continent was like some desolate
Desert. Plant life was THRIVING in the Americas for thousands of years before European settlers showed up with their fancy beehives
So how is that possible?
Is everything we've been told about honeybees being an essential part of the ecosystem and a vital part of the reproductive
lifecycle of flowers wrong well yea. A-and no but yeah you see pollinators are
ABSOULUTELY vital
75% of all crops require pollination however the idea that honeybees are a critical part of that process in the      U.S.
Is a complete and utter?
Myth first these black and yellow striped. Honeybees aren't the only type of bee out there. There are more than
20,000 species of bees yeah
20,000 the black and yellow stripe be kind known formerly as the apis mellifera
This formerly is the Western honeybee is just one of them for example take Agra post him on a genus of bee
That sounds more like a rejected Digimon than an insect critical for sustained plant life on earth
digivolve into
These insects do make honey
And they look nothing like Barry be Benson or the bees that we're all familiar with but these little green guys are bees nonetheless
They're known as sweat bees unlike honey bees which get their nutrients by making honey from the nectar of flowers
These feed from the sweat of mammals, and yeah when I say mammals that includes humans
So if you've ever found yourself on a hot day swatting at one of these green gray little bugs that seems to enjoy
Landing on your neck it might not be a flyer wasps
But a sweat thirsty be trying to get a taste of that salty secretion. Let me lick your neck
So yeah, if you're starting to feel like you've been lied to your whole life about bees well
You kind of have been let's just rip that band-aid off entirely right now bees aren't just yellow and black only a very few species
Actually make honey most don't do that twerk dance that we've been taught that they do for most bees
Stinging does not mean death if they even sting at all and those twenty thousand species of bees aren't the only
pollinators out there pollen wasps ants butterflies moths even some species of beetle can get the job done too top story a
Tri-county bee Barry Benson is saying he intends to sue the human race for stealing our
So if the world's honey economy were thrown into turmoil by a lawsuit set in motion by a talking
Honeybee you somehow figured out how to work the American legal system no problem
There'd actually be plenty of other
Non-dancing equally hard-working bees out there to pick up the slack or at least there would have been if it wasn't for Barry B
Benson in the first place
That's right, Barry and the rest of the Western honeybees are murderers
But you don't see anyone putting them on trial at least until today
And you had better BEE-lieve that this insect uprising needs to be squashed! What I mean is that there are?
Conservationists out there who believe that the environment would be better off without
Honeybees remember how I said honey bees are an invasive species brought in by the colonists well according to dr.
Jonas Gelman of the University of Cambridge honey bee hives harm the environment by crowding out all the other local
pollinators quote there's increasing evidence that unnaturally high densities of honeybees
associated with beekeeping can exasperate declines in wild pollinators
Besides competing with wild species for resources honeybees are linked to the spread of diseases to wild pollinators
via shared flowers an effect, that's likely amplified by trade, width and movement of
Honeybees end quote. This isn't just some random guy ranting on his blog on the internet. This was published in Nature
Nature the scientifically reputable magazine
Not.you know nature hasn't published in the woods
It's not like this guy was pulling a primitive technology and cueing his article into the side of a tree this shall be my legacy
anyway
His conclusions aren't all that surprising
anytime you introduce a new species to an environment or
Often than not it's gonna have negative consequences on the local species because the invader doesn't have any natural predators and may be better suited
to survive the new climate
actually go much more in depth in this episode covering the invasive species of the Pokemon verse over on game theory so sting that I
Icon after the episode - check it out
But when it comes to western honeybees the data is there in another nature article published by first the author's track the global decline of
Bumblebees which again to be clear are different from Western honeybees they also don't make honey
But bumblebees are on the decline
And it's the honeybee diseases spilling over into their
Populations that are causing it won't again wild pollinators
Such as bumblebees are in global decline when cause of which may be a pathogen spillover from managed pollinators like
Honeybees the prevalence of deformed wing virus and the exotic parasite knows MLAT name in honey bees and bumblebees is
Linked as honey bees have higher deformed wing virus prevalence and sympatric bumble bees and honey bees are
infected by the same dwv strains apis remember
That's Latin name for Western honeybees is the likely source of at least one major
emerging infectious disease in wild pollinators end quote
And they're not the only ones to conclude this another study again looking at the impact honeybees are having on bumble bee
Populations concluded the following given the available evidence, it's likely the pathogen spillover from commercial bees is contributing to the ongoing
Decline of wild bumble bees in North America and that's only one of the ways the honeybees are actually killing off their fellow
pollinators!
When you look at insects honeybees are unique because they actually remove nectar from flowers
In order to make their honey while other insects are able to pollinate flowers without stealing the nectar
Well that might not seem like that big of a deal this paper by Diane Thompson at the University of California, Santa Cruz
found that the Western honeybees strategy of creating nectar scarcity for other species insures that the
competition produced fewer offspring
What a final time these results provide evidence tha
Apis competitively suppress a native social be known to be an important pollinator with the potential for
Cascading effects on native plant communities these have never been afraid to change the world
Yeah, change it for the worse berry sit your bumble butt down Seinfeld
I'm not done with you because if that wasn't enough honey bees have one final secret advantage in all of this. They live in
protected communities unlike other pollinators who have to fend for themselves in the wild honey bees because they're
Agricultural animals are protected by their farmers thus giving them a survival advantage
It's a whole heck of a lot easier for an insect species to survive when it gets to live in a safe little box on
a farm! berry seems to think that honeybees are an important part of the environment
But not could be further from the truth when it comes to ecological problems Barry isn't part of the solution
He's part of the problem in a way the conclusion of the 🅱🅴🅴-movie is actually right about one thing
Humans and honeybees do share a critical symbiotic relationship without human demand for honey
Honeybee populations would collapse and fall into disrepair as mother nature
Exacting a revenge on the invasive species that for so many years has kept the native insect
Populations at bay Barry be Benson throughout the movie likes to pretend that
Honeybees are the victim that they exist under the oppressive thumb of the evil human farmers
But as this one has come true for you exploiting tiny helpless bees
But Barry you and all those other Western honeybees we see throughout
This movie are the real problem the real victims here are the native insect species whose
Territory you've encroached on who you've deprived of nectar, and who you've out competed
Thanks in large part to humanity's protection in the courtroom Barry raises a chant of really these bees
Free the bees indeed free the
19900 99 other bee species that the imperialist Western honeybees have been keeping down for hundreds of years
Maybe then nature can exist the way, it was originally meant to but hey
That's just a theory!
A FILM THEORY!
bzzzzzzzzzzzzzz
Cut. won't you BEE a friend and join the loyal?
Theorists? Click that subscribe button and while you're clicking things make sure you click that box to the right to find out more about invasive
Species and how cute animals across the world are dying? That's that game theory episode?
I mentioned earlier now if you'll excuse me it's time for me to buzz off
I don't know. I got nothing here at least until next week. I'll see you then